l'ombre du conflit au Proche Orient la
guerre en Ukraine elle se poursuit la
Russie affirme avoir intercepté
aujourd'hui neuf drones Ukrainiens qui
volit près de la centrale nucléaire de
zaporida dans le sud Kiev a par ailleurs
dénoncé hier la plus vaste attaque russe
depuis le début de l'année sur son
territoire plus de 100 localités ont été
bombardées en 24 heures selon les
autorités le point avec Guliver
Krag dans l'est de l'Ukraine les Russes
sont passés à l'attaque notamment autour
de la ville d'avdivka qu'il cherchent à
prendre maintenant depuis 3 semaines en
redoublant leurs efforts et en subissant
des pertes très importantes sans pour le
moment afficher de succès et les
Ukrainiens continuent leur
contreoffensif dans le sud du pays
surtout dans la région de zapourija
aussi sans afficher vraiment des
avancées notables et c'est ce qui fait
dire à Valérie zalouni chef de
l'état-major ukrainien dans une tribune
publiée dans The Economist le journal
britannique et aussi une interview qui
accompagne cette tribune que la guerre
est rentrée dans une impasse puisqu'il y
a une sorte de parité technologique
entre les deux côtés qui fait que le
côté qui défend arrive presque toujours
à repousser les attaque sauf quand
c'était l'exemple de bakmou la Russie
est déterminée coûte que coûte même en
subissant des pertes de dizaines de
milliers d'hommes de prendre finalement
un tout petit bout de territoire mais
pour Valérie zouni c'est une situation
très dangereuse pour l'Ukraine si la
guerre passe dans une phase
positionnelle attritionnelle puisque la
Russie aura plus d'opportunités de
recruter plus d'hommes et de
manufacturer plus d'armes alors il faut
selon lui que l'Ukraine trouve le moyen
de sortir de cet impasse en regagnant un
avantage technologique bien sûr avec
l'aide de ses partenaires occidental il
appelle à étudier les moyen de gagner un
avantage technologique notamment dans le
domaine des drones et dans les systèmes
de blocage des signaux qui contrôlent
les drones ça c'est une idée parmi
d'autres je vous répète que l'Ukraine ne
voit pas du tout une option que de
négocier avec la Russie pour plusieurs
raisons mais peut-être la raison la plus
importante c'est qu'ils sont convaincus
à Kiev que pour Vladimir Poutine il ne
s'agit pas vraiment de contrôler les
parties de l'Ukraine que la Russie
contrôle actuellement il s'agit de
contrôler tout le pays et donc céder du
territoire ne serait pas pour Kiev une
solution